as an actress you ever go on these sets
and feel like ridiculous you go i wonder
if this is going to play and then you
start getting self-conscious or are you
just that confident
i was worried about the act because i
thought
if i do a bad job i knew that this show
could ruin my career
because of how crazy the material was
does patricia arquette ever say to you
hey
joey pull you aside and say uh you're
pulling this off or hey you're not
pulling this off
because i mean i'm glad you asked that
her and i had this
i would say honest system honor system
but about four days into shooting the
first episode
like she had just done a couple of takes
of a close-up of her and she
turned around and looked at me and she
was like hey
was that okay and i was like oh my what
like obviously it was okay or patricia
arquette
um and she was like no no like i'm
serious was that okay i was like
yeah it was really it was really great
like you seemed really
upset frantic and as you should be in
the scene she was like okay
from this point on she goes i trust you
i trust your skill level and i trust
your instinct i was like oh [ __ ] that's
a huge compliment
and she was like uh from this point on i
think you and i need to be honest with
each other
if we don't think something's good and
if we think that the other person should
ask for another take or anything of that
nature
so did you ever tell her we did we
and and it felt very strange sometimes
to like tell patricia arquette like hey
maybe ask for one more
but she became so much more than
than patricia arquette to me and her and
i have an
amazing relationship now even the show's
over we were able to do that for each
other and be able to play these
traumatizing roles together it was so
fun
i mean it really was an amazing uh uh
performance and
uh yeah the other thing i read about
that too was you had to do nude scenes
in there and that
patricia arquette cause she's been
through uh everything in hollywood
she basically said to um everyone on the
set hey you're going to clear the set
b cover the cameras when we're not
shooting charge it was amazing she was
amazing because i'd never had that
experience before
and she was like all right this is how
we're going to do this and i felt
so loved and protected by her she's i
mean she's the best